I've been using Apple's air pods for
over two years and I love them and now
Apple has released the updated air pods
with the new h1 chip which actually does
make ear pods work better and more
reliably that same chip is packed into
the power beats Pro which is awesome on
top of that the para beats actually get
physical controls including a more
reliable physical button to pause switch
tracks and use Siri if you don't want to
use the new hey Siri feature it also
gets something that I really truly wish
the air pods had volume controls on the
earphones themselves and it's also in a
pretty convenient location as well
unlike the air pods the power beets wrap
around your ears so they don't budge at
all no matter what kind of activity
you're doing but in most cases the air
pods won't fall out either one thing I
did notice was that the power beats
probe were nowhere near as comfortable
in your ears as the ear pods over long
periods of time your ears actually start
to get a bit tired over time and that
doesn't happen with the air pots it's
also much quicker and easier to get air
pods in your ears the power beats Pro
definitely require a bit more work to
wrap around your ears and may take some
time to get used to now the sound
quality is noticeably better on the
power beats Pro unlike air pods they
create a seal inside of your ear so they
sound louder block out background noise
and there's much more bass like much
more seriously if you really love bass
just pay the extra cash for the power
beats Pro now are they the best sounding
wireless earphones you can buy at that
$250 price point no definitely not you
can probably find better sounding ones
for a lower price but it doesn't matter
because there's something missing with
the other guys that beautiful beats logo
over the years beats by dre has made a
name for itself by creating beautifully
designed high quality headphones with
great audio quality and almost everyone
knows that yes you can go on Amazon and
research for hours trying to find better
sounding earphones for a cheaper price
but with Beats you can trust that
they're gonna work great and sound great
and that's why you'll pay extra for them
not only that but people around you know
that beats are expensive and if you're
wearing them it means you're doing well
financially and that's why bees will
have no problem selling these however
you also get that same effect with the
air pods so it's ultimately going to
happen
the Apple fans are gonna buy the air
pods and beets fans are gonna buy the
powerbeats Pro now what if you like both
well let's look at the downsides of the
power beets the biggest downside is the
massive case just look at how much
larger it is in the air pods case and
even at that size it still doesn't
include wireless charging why well I
think they'd have to charge $300 for it
and that could make even beats fans
think twice the tiny ear pods case is
incredibly convenient because you can
easily put it into your pocket and take
it anywhere but with the power beats Pro
the case is so huge that it's really
impractical to squeeze it into your
pocket and carry it around but on the
plus side the battery life on the power
beats pro lasts nine hours compared to
five with air pots so you don't have to
pop them back into the case for charging
quite as often so you can leave the case
behind and when you do have to charge
them a quick five minute charge gets you
one and a half hours of playback another
minor drawback is that you can only
charge the case using a lightning cable
which isn't as widely available as USBC
and I also notice another small issue
with the power beats with the air pod so
you can easily flick open the top with
one hand while you put your ear pods
back with the other with power beats Pro
it's extremely difficult to open with
one hand so most of the time you're
gonna have to use two hands to open it
now that may sound a little far-fetched
but these are the little differences
you'll notice daily with that said the
power beats Pro are still excellent
earbuds that are a little on the pricey
side
thanks to that beats by dre batch but if
you like long battery life physical
controls and great sounding bass you'll
love these earphones now if you prefer
comfort and convenience and saving some
cash I think you'll be very happy with
the air pods as well if you enjoyed this
review tap that like button and click
that circle above to subscribe thanks
for watching and we'll see you in the
next video
[Music]